[Laughter]
[Music]
g'day i'm the resident nature nerd at
abc science
we got plenty of deadly animals here in
australia
so now it's time to look around the
world cameron your dips
today we're hunting down dangerous urban
animals
from home invaders
to murderous vandals and
i'll be speaking to a man who fought off
a killer cat
you could smell what what smelt like
just death like rotted flesh
i've scoured the internet for the best
videos to discover
which of these five animals are truly
deadly
they're one of the planet's most hearty
and successful
species cockroaches they are deadly it's
just not their
own fault
[Music]
ah that's why the phone wasn't working
then
cockroaches like to live in all sorts of
dank hidey holes
no matter who you are or where you're
from they make you scream
oh no it's somewhere
[Music]
you know oh you're gonna destroy your
whole house looking for it
they're great at squeezing into tiny
little places
they can flatten themselves out a bit to
make sure
[Laughter]
i mean they do often surprise you when
they start to fly
as a general rule cockroaches aren't
great
flyers they do have wings obviously two
pairs in fact
one of those pairs has evolved to be
hard
and it actually protects the soft wings
that are underneath
that means that their steering and
ability to
go long distances is is hampering
these cockroaches i decapitated last
night
okay is the most
violent episode of how deadly yet
and then i went to bed and this morning
they're still kicking so they're not
like us they're not going to bleed
out right and in fact if their heads get
chopped off the wound sort of seals over
in each segment the cockroach has an
agglomeration
of nerves and they sort of keep the
function going so
even without the brain it can still you
know it has a nervous system and it
keeps on sort of running and
if you touched it it would react but
without a mouth you go pretty hungry
and they only last about two weeks
[Music]
well i'm in my living room i'm walking
back and forth you ever see something
moving in your peripheral vision
and it wasn't supposed to be there we've
all been there
it's gone i waited too long i don't know
where it's at
the cat probably ate it it was right
there when i
saw it last time it was cold and like
it was normal he can't find it
because they're amazing at hiding
cockroaches are able to compress
themselves down
to fit into tiny little cracks that are
maybe a quarter
of the overall height of the cockroach
it's a pretty
incredible thing to do especially when
you think about the fact they've got
an exoskeleton they're hard on the
outside but that's one of the reasons
that
engineers like to study insects like
cockroaches
these are millions of years of
perfect nature wrapped into one creature
where's it at baby's good attack do your
jobs cats
you you jobless little you you attack
that
find it the cat looks like it's it's
used to emotions
really i hope ice food's all open and
stuff
so cockroaches are what we call
mechanical
vectors they can move pathogens or
disease
things from place to place
because they like to crawl around in
drains and they like to crawl
over our faces and in our toilets and
across our food it's the
cross-contamination
that is the issue we gotta dance though
we got his ass
one behind him it's behind you
i don't even know what to say that's not
how to get rid of [ __ ] creatures
[Music]
did he put petrol on it or something to
try and burn them
it's really hard to get rid of
cockroaches they're really adaptable and
they've been able to
even adapt some of their physiological
processes to get around our bait
[Music]
while we might not like the cockroaches
we can't just
wipe them out there are thousands of
species of cockroaches that are
absolutely
integral to our ecosystem function they
form a part
of a little army that ensures that
things
biodegrade in our systems that logs end
up becoming
soil and without them we'd just be
in a world full of refuse
[Music]
[Music]
next up it's pumas the america's
powerful wild cat
and these used to be incredibly
difficult to find because they're so
secretive but now in santiago in chile
san francisco la the pumas are roaming
the streets
[Music]
ah delivery
so sleek in california aren't they
pumas are coming into town all the way
across the americas and this is for a
number of reasons
the main one being the fact that their
habitat
is diminishing they're hungry they need
a place to live and they're going to
come closer and closer
into our towns
no oh
[Music]
hi a lot of faith in that glass don't
they is that
crazy or why oh my god where are the
kids
they're out back tommy are you kidding
me shh you're going to scare the cat
[ __ ]
they're still in there
that is not funny you better give me a
heart
pumas are sometimes known as mountain
lions and apart from humans
they have the largest geographical range
of any mammal
in the americas they are found all the
way from canada
right down to the pointy end of chili
there's something like
40 names just in english for this
creature
they're known as pumas cougars mountain
lions mexican lions
catamounts mountain screamers
cat of god that one's a good one
oh that's the catwall
sounds like she's had a bottle of
whiskey and 10 packs of cigarettes
they don't raw they're not in the big
cat family they're actually more closely
related to
a domestic cat they do all sorts of
mules
they purr whistles little shrieks and
a famous one a catawall
it'd be terrifying if you heard it and
you're out there alone
hey hey oh
go on go on
i'm not going to shoot you go look at it
considering
starting to crouch
hey oh dear
hey hey ah look at it
you're gonna get me look at it
go on go on
oh god oh dear is back
or is it just because of that stick oh
no just having a sit down
its ears are up and forward which means
it's pretty happy
and curious they can take prey items
sometimes apparently as big as a horse
if you want to know what an aggressive
puma looks like
you have to think of an aggressive
domestic cat it will
crouch hiss put its ears down
and flat it'll reveal its teeth
it'll pump its legs potentially ready to
attack or defend itself
he was doing the right thing making
himself sound very big
another thing to do is if you've got a
coat on or anything like that is to open
it up
and make yourself look very big if
you're with a friend
you can stand together because that
makes you look like you're
you're an unassailable mass
despite sharing our living areas with
pumas attacks
are really quite rare in canada and the
us there's only four to six
attacks every year i spoke with someone
who survived an attack
my first thought was i was so excited i
mean it's right here look at this line
this is
beautiful i had a little knife so while
the line
was sitting there not on whatever it was
under the tree i pulled that out i
started folding in the blades and it
made a snap sounds
that echoed we were eye to eye same
looked me dead in the eyes
and launched boom slammed into me we
landed ten feet down the mountainside
and the bottom claws all immediately
went into my like
my thighs down by my knees to get hold
the top claws you could hear the pop
sounds pop pop pop pop on each side of
my neck
the bottom jaw was in the gist and the
top part of my forehead by the hairline
the top jaw was in the back part of my
head and just pulled me down like this
vice grip
i mean just the strength i couldn't move
the strength was so tough
you could smell what what smell like
just death like rotted flesh
it's you know the throat was right here
as hard as i could i started stabbing
and digging and
just trying to bust open that fur which
was so so tough
and the cat obviously didn't care for
that
took two swings towards my face a loud
pop and tear
sound as it connected four inch gash
under my left eye
and all i heard was that raking sound
just
with the teeth raking but that's when
everything started flashing through my
head
and i knew real quickly that my time was
quickly disappearing
and that's when i just scream oh god
help me and i get this awesome
adrenaline boost and i reached over
and my thumb shoved into the right eye
it went
through the eyelid around the eyeball to
the back muscle and as hard as i could
shove my thumb into its eye
i know that did some damage to him and
stunned him enough
i took a swing to the top of the head
and this loud
squeal baby chirp type sound
just just echoed out of this line and
the claws
popped on my neck and the jaws loosened
up and i threw my head
back kind of up out of its range and i
jumped back 10 feet up onto the trail
i'm looking back the whole way help
please don't chase me please don't chase
me scared to death
i got down and just get to the bottom
and you can have your life back
i don't blame the lion at all zero
i have the utmost respect for these
animals it literally felt threatened by
me
or it felt like i was after its meal or
what have you
my my advice would be know your
surroundings
be prepared just make sure you can run
faster than the person you're hiking
with
that is a lucky break for both him and
the puma perhaps
how did you get in there
oh that is phenomenal
it's a pretty good idea give it multiple
ways to get
out and make a sound
that makes you sound bigger than you
are oh
they're not really interested in us and
they're not really interested in your
interior decorating either
the thing is is that if you invite prey
items
into your backyard with a water point or
a feeding point
you are going to invite predators into
your backyard
hey hey hey so yeah they are
deadly so if you see one near your place
thank you lucky stars and call the
authorities
[Music]
we've got even better videos to come so
don't go anywhere
[Music]
wild boars are usually roaming forests
and grasslands and coming out to annoy
farmers and eat all their crops
so what are they doing trotting around
the streets and should we be worried
[Music]
they live in big family groups led by
a matriarch lots of grunting going on
grunting is used for communication
within the group
and it's often the females who are
[Music]
grunting
[Music]
is it in the clothes shop it falls
through the roof
[Music]
wild boar's coming in for a myriad of
reasons some of
which is habitat destruction but also
drought
so they come in to find water sources as
well as getting into the rubbish
[Music]
look at that head i actually think
they're pretty cute
am i weird
you're a damn big animal they've found
in their tummies all sorts of stuff
including human prepared foods very
often like you know
ham sandwiches which in turn means
that they're getting a bit chubby and
some of the wild boars are like 35
fatter than their cousins which are
living outside the city limits
[Music]
your guys are like what just
open the door yeah
just open the door
uh leave the door
that's that's problem solving for you
right there
it's hard to test the intelligence of
wild gore but what we do know
about domesticated pigs is that they are
extremely
intelligent scientists have done all
manner of tests
about this including putting mirrors in
with pigs
scientists found that the pigs were not
only able to
situate themselves but also use the
mirror as a tool to situate
other things and on top of that when
they put the mirrors in the pigs spent a
long time admiring themselves which i
sort of love
of self-love now they spent a long time
admiring themselves and actually
changing their angles
and and looking and and and looking
and as they were doing that they were
actually sort of like calibrating their
spatial brain
as to what was in the mirror themselves
and what else the mirror reflected
so how do you outsmart a wild boar
oh okay
badly thought through did he just bend
that on its back
ah there's such a ball of muscle aren't
they
oh apparently not very good eyesight
which
that would support and boop into the
whoa look at that speed
[Music]
you can see how its tusks would be a
real problem once the man fell on the
ground
there are many people who get injured
and some
even die it almost seems
completely disoriented and frenzied like
it doesn't know what to do and because
they all keep on moving and posing
a problem and being like really
intimidating it just keeps on going
and winning
[Music]
so what to do if a wild boar comes
towards you
keep your footing get up high if you
possibly can up onto a car or in a tree
something like that
really helps and make sure you give it
an escape route
butters they are cute
and curious are they also murderous
the otter is clearly saying go away
i mean you don't have to be an honor
expert to know that that odd is upset
he's protecting his babies
cameron you did i told him to go in
there
this is what i believe we call super
cute
so these are sea otters sea otters
actually spend almost all of their time
at sea in the water in fact the females
will even
give birth in the water and suckle their
young and pull them up onto their chest
so it isn't unusual to see them sleeping
on the water
unlike other seagoing mammals like seals
they don't have a layer of blubber to
protect them
from the cold they have this amazing fur
they have the most dense fur of
any animal on the planet it's a one inch
square it's
up to one million hair follicles
she put her hand on his mouth
i can't even believe they're real
[Applause]
how cool is that
back 1977 there was a big campaign in
singapore to clean
up the harbour and it has worked
even though it's a big you know super
city the otters have been able to
recolonize back into singapore and there
are 10
families of otters that live in the city
limits people know them
by name
where you going with that one of the
things that the singapore otters have
been doing
is stealing koi out of ponds
it is a big fish and these little guys
use
a lot of energy every day so much so
that they need to eat 25 of their body
weight
in fish and shellfish every single day
so this is a real conservation success
story in some ways
that these smooth otters are able to
live to cohabitate with humans in such a
densely populated environment
[Music]
[Music]
you know orders don't generally attack
people there's generally a reason
you might not know that you've
antagonized theodore but you may well
have antagonised the other you may be
too close to its babies it might be
rabid
all of the normal suspects but then
there is a couple of stories
about otters that make you go
hmm
[Music]
sea otters in particular have a very
poor reputation
when it comes to the manner in which
they copulate
a study found that of 105 otters that
were found
deceased 11 of those otters had injuries
that would have been inflicted during
mating or copulation it goes a little
bit further with sea otters in
particular though
because they have been observed
fornicating
with deceased juvenile harbour seals
yeah so you thought otters were cute eh
[Music]
so yeah otters can be unexpectedly
violent
but generally it's aimed at critters
that are smaller than the orders
themselves
doesn't mean you're not going to get run
at by an order at some point and if you
do
just clear out
rats have a reputation for spreading
disease but in modern times
are they really that bad
[Music]
is the cat going to help
[Applause]
oh the cat the cat's scared
he squashed his cat the bastard
it's so funny you know it's not a jaguar
it's it's a tiny little rat and it just
creates such
a big hullabaloo for humans
even if you only see one at a time it's
probably not one rat
a female rat can produce four to seven
liters every single year and
each of those litters can have up to ten
individual babies
in it so that's like 40 to 70
individual rats out there so you can see
why when the conditions are really good
these rats can just explode in
population
and take over a whole area
[Music]
if a rat can make it anywhere it's going
to be in new york
in 2014 in new york city there was one
wrap
for every four humans it's like two
million rats
it's a lot of rats there's this
study where they looked inside to see
strat's stomachs to see what they'd been
eating and they found that inside
this rat there were four thousand
different items that had eaten
it's one of the themes of animals that
can make it in the city
is the fact that they have really
diverse diets and can get by
on a slice of pizza
no gold they're not without chops you've
got to give them that
things can turn a little bit nasty
they can get really bold and even turn
cannibalistic
in order to get by another thing that's
really fascinating
in new york is that there's like
the uptown rats and the downtown rats
there's genetic diversion
the rats that overtake new york are
brown rats we do have them here in
australia
but we've also got a whole suite of our
own
native rats swamp rats bush rats popping
mice desert ones dusky ones
my favorite animal in australia is a
water rat
they are the best wrap hands down pours
down
they eat crayfish and crabs
and catch fish with their bare hands
they get out and sit on little rocks and
groom themselves and they're big long
whiskers
they teach their young to hunt it's
thought that
water rats australian native rats will
actually keep out
pest rats and scare them away they're
like australia's otters but without the
necrophilia yo
welcome to generation x where kids walk
with two sets back to their chests
having rats in your food preparation
area is
definitely not ideal they carry about 35
different diseases that can affect
either you
or your pets things like salmonella
or chularemia let me
there's a heap of ways that you can
catch diseases from animals like rats
including getting bitten unsafe handling
or disposal of
dead rats rat urine
or excretia on plates
unsafe preparation of food that's been
nibbled by rats and then eaten by humans
to get rid of rats around your house you
need to make it the opposite of ratty
heaven
nowhere to hide no food to eat and
they're not gonna stop at your house
as soon as it stopped acting like prey
the cats stopped treating it like prey
oh god cats are funny
[Music]
so rats can be affected by a toxicity
that affects your brain function and
they develop a sort of unnatural and
probably
unwise attraction to the smell of
[Music]
catway
it's bizarre right that a rat would be
attracted towards cats
but the smart thing about this is is
that for the pathogen that caused the
toxoplasmosis to actually replicate
it needs to happen inside the gut of a
cat
so essentially this pathogen that's
infecting the rat
leads it like a pied piper directly to
the source
and says here you go eat this and then
into the tummy it goes
look it's chasing it down the street
[Applause]
rats and the pathogens that they carry
are dangerous
but they're an inescapable part of
living in a city
[Music]
cities aren't biological wastelands
they're full of species
super secretive predators and
near-perfect organisms
that are gonna make the best of whatever
we throw at them
so as our urban creep gets bigger
and bigger it's us we're the ones that
need to find a way
to live harmoniously with the animals
around us see you next time
hey thanks for watching i also host a
shorter version of this series
it's only about australian animals like
magpies
you should be able to find it somewhere
here and remember subscribe because we
upload new videos every week
that way you won't miss out on them and
i'll see you then